[Music]
GDP is comprised of growth in the
workforce and then growth in
productivity so if you have slowing
workforce growth that tells you that
that's going to create a real headwind
for GDP growth and it means that if
you're gonna have more than sluggish GDP
growth you're gonna need more growth
from productivity immigrants and their
children based on our work at the Dallas
Fed have made up more than half of the
workforce growth in the United States in
the last 20 years immigrants and their
children and it's our judgment that in
the next 20 years that percentage will
be even higher because existing
workforce is aging and will age out of
the workforce so while it's very
controversial and a sensitive subject
obviously we're gonna need to come to
grips in this country at some point with
immigration reform that that helps us
find a way to grow immigration and I
believe that is going to be an essential
element also of growing the workforce in
the years ahead the ten-year Treasury is
lower interest rates generally across
the curve are lower than we've
historically become accustomed there's
number of reasons for that but one of
them is I think the markets are
expecting relatively sluggish GDP growth
in the years ahead and one of the
primary reasons for that is slowing
again workforce growth so Japan is a
great example of an economy that is
suffering from aging demographics to a
greater extent even than the United
States and as a result of that their
their GDP growth has steadily declined
the problem is culturally and
structurally there's not a lot they are
able to do meaning they've worked on
getting women back into the workforce or
getting them to participate their
greater degree in the workforce but
that's basically run its course and they
are not as they're not culturally
receptive to immigration back to the
United States we've also had a trend in
the US where women increasingly joined
the workforce and that helped workforce
growth
that trend is also plateaued the the
reality is unless we take some action
we're going to have very sluggish work
growth workforce growth in the years
ahead so what are some actions that
could be taken to address it
number one we call it skills training
workforce development middle skills
training that means there's a skills gap
in the United States there are more
skilled job openings than there are
supply of skilled workers most surveys
we do and that we read show that many
companies are finding they cannot fill
skilled jobs ok so if you could get to
scourge workers trained in in what's
likely to be a local partnership between
a junior college a high school and local
businesses and you can get them trained
and back into the workforce that grows
the workforce and to extent you'd
retrain people who are already in the
workforce that grows productivity the
second thing that historically this
country has done to to grow the
workforce has been immigration obviously
fertility helps but it helps 20 25 years
from now with a lag and so if we don't
take some action we're gonna have
slowing workforce growth in the next 20
years and it's gonna create a headwind
for GDP growth
[Music]